cette non non les temps d'écouter le
réquisitoire au nom de la société du
procureur général de la république des
proches françaises ont le visage dur qui
nous fait écouter la musique
[Musique]
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés
messieurs les stein chéri ce 30 août
vers midi un soleil brûlant perce le
ciel plombé d'un pari torride écrasée de
chaleur moite la villette exemple nul
arbres ne tremble nul l'oiseau ne pepy
le vent retient son souffle
la cité se meurt dans l'attentes
voluptueuses de la pluie libératrice et
c'est tours ouest jusqu'à là ça va je
déclare tous il a copié la copier le
casse pas mon ambiance d'orage
descendants descendante à pas lent le
boulevard arago le front en sueur et les
bras lourds un classant esseulé au bord
de l'insolation ne peut retenir ce cri
al hallaj les bonbons qui a à la la
comme il fait chaud ah là là que deux
choses qui réjouit la chaux est bien oui
c'est l'orage et soudain trouant le
silence comme un tonnerre de métal
toutes les cloches du xiiie
arrondissement se met à sonner à toute
volée merci pour l'ambiance sonore les
persiennes clause s'ouvre une à une la
rue s'anime en courant se bousculent la
rumeur confus se propage de boutiques en
porte cochère et finalement l'incroyable
nouvelle éclate
roger pierre est menée par roger pierre
est né écrit la boulangère
roger pierre est né hurle le bedeau
rejet pierreville inaki crime être
heureux rigaud qui entre les deux
guerres déjà parlé prenait un malin
plaisir à saboter notre belle langue
française
[Rires]
quand roger pierre est né ce 30 août
son père était tailleur certes mais sa
mère était là c'est quand même
mais on ne vient pas au monde dans une
famille aussi dissolue sans être dès le
berceau frappés au sceau de la
délinquance et déjà mesdames et
messieurs les jurés dès les premiers
jours alors qu'il n'est encore qu'un
joufflu poupon déjà et l'as rome les
pierres ricanant pissant dans ces
couches ses premiers rototo ont l'accent
crapuleux des banlieues ouvrières et
c'est un rare eux sont franchement
menaçant à l'égard de la famille la
famille qui reste le dernier rempart de
l'occident contre le collectivisme le
totalitarisme le bolchevisme et la
suppression du tiercé à 5 francs à six
mois roger pierre n'était pas grand il
montrait son rang son caractère haineux
à tout propos à tous les passants quand
sa nounou passait à sa portée alors
qu'il jouait dans son parc
il lui pince est cruellement le derrière
c'était relativement facile c'était une
nounou plutôt bas du plutôt petit plutôt
petit avec avec un q si bas qui fait
l'humilité encore pardon à ce camp dont
roger pierre traîne déjà derrière lui a
passé chargé de délinquance honteuse
mais ce n'est qu'un début car site alors
qu'angel cette deuxième nourrice qui je
le souligne pour l'anecdote pour tesla
déculottant en amiante pas folle c'est
alors qu'angel va décider a
volontairement de l'avenir criminelle de
l'odieux enfant en lui offrant son
premier costume marin à peine le petit
range y à t'il ce costume sur le sur le
dos que se mirant dans la glace il
s'écrie ini dit quand je serai grand je
serai travelo puis se tournant vers
angèle qui le regardent attendri il
s'écrit que s'écrie-t-il vivant gel bien
sûr voilà
il aurait pu parler communisme avec ma
marque c'est angèle ils sont très connus
les éléphants c'était des rigolos voilà
mesdames et messieurs les jurés comment
dès sa plus tendre enfance
l'infâme roger pierre est déjà marquée
par les deux grands pôles d'attraction
de sa vie dissolue
les costumes marin et la publicité
facile à 20 ans l'accusé est diplômé de
la chambre de commerce de paris le
diable lui était en lui
peut-être fusse-t-il devenu un jour chef
de rayon dans un grand magasin qui sait
voilà un métier honorable monsieur
pierre d'autant qu'avec de la volonté du
travail
rien dans ce pays rien n'empêche qu'un
jour un chef de rayon sauce dans
l'échelle sociale
jusqu'à devenir chef de diamètre mais
non mesdames et messieurs les jurés à
cette vie honorable accusé préfère se
vautrer dans la fange du port
d'amsterdam où il ya des marins qui font
des choses que la morale réprouve
oui monsieur le président c'est dans
l'est dans les ports que roger pierre
au volant de sa voiture et vêtu de son
éternel costume marin pour passer
inaperçu incite d'autres jeunes marins à
la bagarre a certes on ne peut pas dire
que roger pierre qui roule n'agace pas
de mousse au port parallèle morts
[Applaudissements]
parallèlement le démon de la publicité
est si fort en lui que brusquement roger
pierre quitte tout pour s'enfuir vivre
une idylle honteuse avec qui je vous le
demande avec avec la mère denis pour
unique voyage monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
je réclame pour l'accuser roger pierre
une peine exemplaire et maritime à la
fois puisqu'il aime tant les choses de
la mer je propose qu'on l'exil sur une
île déserte avec jacques avec jane
birkin pour qu'ils puissent faire de la
planche à poil on prend forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait étonnant non
[Musique]